so welcome to another episode of tiger
belly
welcome you know um i didn't know
oh you knew
ah i did i didn't you knew there was a
snake in the mail
accusations anyway we got the human
embodiment here i'm gonna make a sound
and you tell me if it reminds you of you
going to the post office okay okay
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
it's it seems familiar
yeah yeah
wait in line at the post office bubbie
so um theo vaughn oh you little spiked
skunk hey [ __ ] you
hey bro hey bro don't call me that you
want to bring a swordfish to a gunfight
you little piss guppy
don't say that
i'm a piss cop you sent me those dirty
dishes and you sent the snake bubba
first of all i don't know where the [ __ ]
you live in nashville number two it's
like why would i if i was gonna
were they poisonous the snakes
the snake was a rat snake bub right bub
can they kill you bob huh can they kill
you bob they can't kill me
why huh you only send one
right right if you want to kill me
you need to say maas
so yeah so i would have sent maybe 10 of
them right and they're more poisonous
than the whatever the gutter one was
that the rat one what's the gutter
whatever the rat snake would i could
send them it was a rat snake rat snake i
was in the box it was dishes that that
was sent
you know this it was dishes that was
sent it was little uh chinese little
cups or something like kind of shaped
like this and had those spoons it also
has a you know the spoon you all have
that as a bowl on the end it's kind of
[ __ ] cheating honestly but you know
what
what do you mean just the really deep
ones yes i do just oh you mean for the
soup yeah for whatever yeah they're soup
[ __ ] spoons bro
is it a
it's a spoon yeah yeah whatever dude
these [ __ ] little pinoy ladles you
know what
yeah yeah
okay dude
the things you scoop up all your
[ __ ]
yeah yeah anyway it's a box of little
asian dishes they're all wrapped in
newspaper uh-huh so i open it up there's
no return address it's from los angeles
but there's it says on the sticker thing
but there's no
um
return address
so i'm like i wonder who sent this
literally i go do some other stuff in my
house i come back over there three
minutes later and there's a snake right
outside of it that's moving around in my
home
whoa where do i live bubby
a wall wasn't that funny
because
my intention i think i came here
bro bro my bro
if i wanted to
if i wanted to kill you you'd be dead
already
right yeah so i do things for a chuckle
yeah right so when you saw the little
dishes and that little bold spoon thing
right and the little
snake right did you get a chuckle out of
it
no i thought who sent me the chinese
ramekins or whatever right right right
but after you went through that thought
process right you thought elise sent it
and that's funny i thought who do i know
that's chinese or semi-chinese yeah i'm
not chinese though semi a semi-chinese i
am semi-chinese but if you played your
cards right you could have been
all right you mean before i even came to
earth i'm just saying dude
if you do your bts [ __ ] work you
[ __ ] show up like you want right
okay i [ __ ] it up up there huh before
i came i'm not saying that but right
it's been said yeah
all right okay i'm just saying so don't
send me snake bro all right bro
my bad dude okay i thought i was gonna
get a charcoal but my bad dude very
scary yeah okay you know how hard it was
to get that snake
i had to go all the way to monterey park
to get that okay
there was a restaurant over there there
are mexican peoples dressed up like
asian people selling snakes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay half that park is a bunch
of agents and finding your address was
tough bro yeah really yeah public
knowledge okay all right but you know
what i thought it was gonna be funny but
i apologize man if it scared you a
little bit it did scare me yeah yeah are
you gonna send me something or what
let's keep in mind that i open all the
mail so it's gotta be something
oh
well have you heard that justin
timberlake song what is it
what's wrong there's so many dude the
one with the uh it's like mail they sent
yeah
it's like a um dick in the box oh is
that it no
this guy dude
this guy i would never send that and
that is a joke interesting you just
shouldn't laugh either okay
yeah mark [ __ ] white berg over there
just freaking oh one of owen benjamin's
henchmen
yeah yeah okay
[Music]
the word calm is amazing
it really is you know what it sounds
like
um yeah that's what i'm saying um when
you when you end it